hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt ich
bin ja heute gibt eine motiv torte und
zwar eine wunschmotiv torte denn viele
von euch haben sich eine torte zum
abschluss gewünscht und überlegt was
mache ich jetzt also habe ich ein
abschluss buch gemacht morath und zwar
hat auch gerade mein bruder den
abschluss gemacht hat nämlich seinen
meister in elektrotechnik gemacht und
hab ich gesagt jetzt mach ich beides
zusammen macht einen abschluss buch für
euch und packt das ganze so ein dass ich
eben die toleranz schenken kann
und weil er schokoladentorte gerne lebt
habe ich da unten drin eine
schokoladentorte mit schokoladen gerne
und habe das ganze dann dekoriert mit
fondant und muttertier schokolade buch
genau und zwar ist es das buch viel zu
schnelle meldung war es weil ich es noch
möglich ja ich ja und zwar habe ich hier
dieses buch gemeint ist sieht dann aus
wie so ein jahr wie so ein ledereinband
und da hab ich elektrotechnik drauf
geschrieben weil er eben den
elektrotechnik meister gemacht hat und
unten dran habe ich einen meisterbrief
morath mit dem sally säge und ich hoffe
du hast die handwerkskammer backhäuser
bemerkt mit dem bartoli fälschern muss
ich sagen das würde ich alles gefärbt so
war das warten
uns fehlt noch so eine stelle und du
bist jung die präsidentin natürlich und
natürlich bin ich ihr präsident
ich glaube unser bürgermeister freut
sich wenn jetzt das wappen von waghäusel
auf youtube sieht unser bürgermeister
ist eine unserer größten zuschauer
seitdem ich die die hsv bosse hat
außerdem sei es für ihn
na ja auf jeden fall wollte ich nur kurz
sagen das war eine richtig tolle stadt
ist und ich deswegen dieses tolle warten
darauf klagen
bürgermeister heiler ist auch ein ganz
toller bürgermeister direkt mit der
torte und ich zeige euch einfach mal wie
ich sie gebacken und dekoriert habe
genau die parkplatzsituation noch
ansprechen
ich habe jetzt hier bereit einen kuchen
gestern abend vorbereitet und zwar habe
ich den saftigen schokoladenkuchen
backen in einer eckigen backform und den
auf eine
20 x 27 cm eingestellt ich finde es
jetzt so eine richtig schöne größe für
ein buch ich habe mich da auch an einem
buch orientiert und habe auch hier eine
zart peter gallas vorbereitet weil er
der kuchen für mein bruder ist und der
schokolade wirklich sehr gerne mag kann
ich die garage erstmal zur seite stellen
und den kuchen lösen
und es ist übrigens ganz normal dass der
teig ein bisschen raus läuft wenn er
etwas flüssiger ist denn dieser kuchen
ist wirklich sehr flüssig und darf am
rand ruhig ein bisschen was raus laufen
aber natürlich nicht so viel
das faktische geht auch zum comeback und
jetzt werde ich den kuchen erst aber mit
einer flotten säge zerteilen
der kuchen ist zwar schon richtig saftig
aber damit dann nochmal saftiger welt
trinke ich ihn jetzt mit etwas
kirschsaft dann kommt auch ein bisschen
frucht mit ins spiel
rees streiche ich noch etwas ganache mit
rein und setzt dann den deckel wieder
drauf
den deckel setze ich jetzt verkehrt
herum auf dann habe ich nämlich oben
direkt eine gerade oberfläche und muss
es eben nicht mehr mit der kanadisch
ausgleichen
jetzt wird die torte erstmal einmal
komplett mit gage eingestrichen
dass es dann die erste krügel schicht
die muss man 15 minuten im kühlschrank
fest werden und dann wird sie noch mal
glatt gestrichen
bevor ich jetzt mit der torte
weitermache bereit ich mein kickboard
vor
und zwar habe ich hier ein dünnes 3 mm
kickboard das ist jetzt quadratisch und
das werde ich jetzt in einer holzoptik
überziehen
dafür habe ich jetzt 500 gramm weißen
von dort genommen und verkneten jetzt
mit einem halben teelöffel cmc prüfer
damit davon dort gleich etwas fester
wird uns schneller aushärtet denn von
dort holte ich jetzt auch etwas becker
stärker aus dadurch klebt er nicht an
der oberfläche und später lässt sich die
bäcker steigt wieder gut weg fordern
dann nehme ich jetzt meinen kickboard
unterstreiche mit essbarem kleber und
zwar trage ich denn jetzt großflächig
auf und verstreichen dann mit einem
pinsel
jetzt soll ich denn von dort wieder über
dem boden aus
hab ich die oberfläche mit einem fordern
gletscher geglättet und auch so an
gedrückt und jetzt kommt die
holzstruktur rein die könnte jetzt
entweder mit einem werkzeug machen oder
in dem zu einer struktur wollen
jetzt mache ich noch die einzelnen
bretter aussehen wie so eine art
holztisch
und die ränder nehme ich jetzt noch weg
mit einem marzipan messer und bevor ich
die platte dann bemalen kann muss erst
mal antrocknen lassen
den restlichen von da nehme ich jetzt um
das buch zu dekorieren und zwar werde
ich jetzt zuerst einmal die seiten
machen und es sind ja die buchseiten
legen muss ich denn von ganz ganz lange
ausrollen
jetzt muss ich da an breiten streifen
ausschneiden und zwar musste jetzt so
breit sein wie die höhe der torte den
streifen mache ich jetzt 5 mm breite da
hat man nämlich so ein bisschen noch
spielraum
es können jetzt einmal mit messer und im
jahr machen oder ihr nehmt einfach diese
skizze klettert höher
und damit es gleich besser auf rollen
kann rollt ich das jetzt hier auf einen
kleinen ausbaustopp auf
und damit der streifen nicht gut an der
torte haftet bespricht die torte
ministers translate und kann dann den
streifen direkt ansetzen und ausrollen
am rand werde ich das jetzt mit deinem
fondant blätter ganz vorsichtig
wo die überreste nämlich vorsichtig mit
einem marzipan messer weg
die überreste da oben nämlich jetzt mit
einem cuttermesser wecker wir können zum
beispiel auch ein scharfes messer
benutzen
jetzt muss ich hier auch noch die
buchseiten markieren und das mache ich
jetzt hier mit einem modell werkzeug
die torte steht erst mal kurz im
kühlschrank damit der weiße rand etwas
an trocknen kann
und die zwischenzeit nutze ich jetzt
oben das skateboard zu bemalen
man könnte es natürlich auch direkt mit
braunem vom bau überziehen aber ich
möchte die holzstruktur ein bisschen
echter machen und nehmen jetzt
lebensmittel verpasste in schwarz zu rot
gelb und blau und mit steht dann
erhalten nämlich ein schönes brown dann
kann ich eben auch hellere und dunklere
stellen machen und das ganze richtig
toll bemalen die farben vermischt mit
einem pinsel und zu versöhnen nehme ich
jetzt etwas alkohol und zwar ist man ja
das skateboard nicht mit ist ja nur der
untergrund deswegen finde ich es auch
nicht schlimm
die farbe sollte nämlich möglichst
schnell trocknen damit sie eben auch
nicht schmiert
dann kann ich das skateboard bemalen
das skateboard darf jetzt noch etwas
trocknen ich habe hier bereits weißen
von dort auch wieder mit 10 0 verknetet
damit trocknet und daraus werde ich
jetzt gleich ein meisterbrief machen das
kommt dann auch noch als unter unterlage
drauf nämlich hier so ein großes ja das
ist eine pappe also auch ein skateboard
und schneit einmal drumherum
und das ist dann aber kurz antrocknen
bevor ich weiter verwenden cookies auf
die weisse platte gezogen und das ist
jetzt erst mal an trockenen aber da wird
ein bisschen plastischer aussieht
nämlich hier so ein holzstäbchen oder
man kann auch dieser schillerlocken
förmchen benutzen und kann das hier so
ein bisschen ein drehen dann sieht es
nämlich später auf der torte plastische
aus
als nächstes will jetzt den buchumschlag
machen und dafür habe ich jetzt ein kilo
schokoladen fondant bereits geknetet und
rollte mit 5 mm dick aus und zwar könnt
ihr das ganz gut machen mit zu zwei
holzstäbchen können natürlich auch
weglassen also man kann nur ungefähr
machen
aber so hat man eben ganz genau
die überreste der bäcker stärke kann man
immer ganz gut mit einem pinsel weg
kinzel
jetzt muss ich noch mal die torte nach
und kann dann dementsprechend ein
rechteck zu schneiden
ihr müsst ihr beim zuschneiden immer
daran denken dass der buchumschlag jetzt
etwas größer wird da der übersteht
jetzt habe ich den umschlag drüber
gelegt und klärte ihn jetzt da hinten
die überreste rechnen
jetzt lege ich dann backpapier drauf und
neben dem zweiten ritter oder eine
tortenplatte egal was irgendwas flaches
und dreht die torte um
jetzt muss ich nur gucken ob die torte
an der tortenplatte festklebt wenn jahre
nehmen dir eine palette und löst sehen
jetzt lege ich dieses 5 mm holzstäbchen
hier an den rand und kann dann in
sauberen run schneiden natürlich kann
bereits zum beispiel auch ein röhrchen
hinlegen oder einfach was anderes was
sie in der küche findet
und um den rand da oben an buchrücken
wegzuschneiden nehmt ihr am besten eine
schere
jetzt muss ich noch die ecken hier
abrunden da kann ich die torte wieder
oben drehen
damit das buch als etwas realistischer
aussieht muss ich jetzt hier noch diese
kleine falte rein machen und zwar ist
sehr dafür da dass man eben den umschlag
und dem buchrücken so bisher
unterscheiden kann ist auch bei echten
büchern so dafür nehme ich jetzt auch
das lineal setzt es an und drückt dann
vorsichtig ein
um dem modell werkzeugs reicht die linie
einfach nochmal nach
jetzt hab ich hier buchstaben ausstich
hat damit ich auf dem buchrücken und auf
der oberfläche eben auch was schreiben
kann
ich schreibe ist natürlich etwas was zum
thema passt bei mir jetzt elektrotechnik
und alles was eben ja alle begriffe die
mir dazu einfallen oder die eben dazu
gehören dafür habe ich jetzt einmal
große ausstecher und kleine aussteller
und da müsste jetzt natürlich schauen
dass es auch von der größe her passt
also die großen passen jetzt hier
wunderbar auf dem buchrücken und die
kleinen passen obendrauf die torte
ständig jetzt kurz in den kühlschrank
und wetzlar weise modelliert schokolade
ausholen und alle buchstaben ausstechen
bevor jetzt die buchstaben an klebe
werde ich jetzt das buch noch etwas
rudern milchpulver farbe dafür habe ich
jetzt so ein dunkles rot und schwarz
gemischt man kennt dabei zum beispiel
auch ein bisschen kakaopulver nehmen und
jetzt mit einem großen pinsel dann sieht
es nämlich so ein bisschen alt aus soll
er wie so ein jahr wieder einem
ledereinband aussehen
und für die buchseiten nämlich ein
bisschen gelb und auch etwas schwarz und
vater ganz vorsichtig drüber
ich habe jetzt noch zwei streifen
zugeschnitten auch aus modelle
schokolade und die befindliches mit
etwas gold bruder und jetzt kann ich die
buchstaben mit etwas essbarem kleber
ankleben und damit ich sie auf die
gleiche höhe kleber habe ich jetzt hier
nochmal dieses holzstäbchen genommen und
unten als run hingelegt und jetzt kommt
immer ganz wenig kleber auf die
rückseite und dann wird der buchstabe
angedrückt
hier unten klebe ich jetzt noch einen
kleinen kreis aus modelliert schokolade
an und zwar kommt da wie so ein kleines
siegel drauf mit einer runden spritzt
hülle kommt jetzt noch ein kleiner kreis
rhein
ich habe jetzt noch diese präge
buchstaben und trägt er einen einigen
damit das aber mein bruder ali heißt
das restliche buch könnte jetzt
natürlich dekorieren wie ihr möchtet ihr
könnt entweder nur ausstecher benutzern
modelle schokolade oder von dort oder
ihr mag noch ein bisschen was drauf das
mache ich jetzt neben dafür etwas pulver
farbe und die kann man an mission mit
wasser oder mit alkohol zum beispiel
unterschreibe ich jetzt eben noch
angaben drauf wie zum beispiel den namen
und ganz viele andere details
die torte sitz im kühlschrank und jetzt
werde ich noch den meisterbrief
fertigmachen und schreibt dafür jetzt
auch wieder alles mit dem pulver farben
die habe ich jetzt auch verdünnt und
nehmen auch dazu noch gleich die
lebensmittel farbstifte
ich habe den meisterbrief fertig und ich
muss jetzt hier auf der linken seite gar
nicht alles beschriften
denn das buch verdeckt ihr dann auch den
teil zum beispiel auf das siegel machen
dafür habe ich jetzt sehr rote modelle
schokolade weiß geknetet und werde dann
mit ausstecher und mitprägen buchstaben
das ganze noch einbringen
seit sind die einzelteile fällt jetzt
kann ich die torte zusammensetzen sollte
man nämlich jetzt das skateboard und den
meisterbrief muss ich jetzt so etwa in
dieses eck also auf diesem weg
platzieren da kommt jetzt etwas
lebensmittels leber hin
hier finde ich eigentlich fast fertig
jetzt muss ich nur noch dem buch hand
unten ankleben
dafür habe ich jetzt bereits schoko von
dann ausgerollt und auch wieder auf fünf
millimeter breite zugeschnitten und ich
habe es jetzt eben noch kurz mit dem
pinsel wieder mit schwarz eingefärbt
damit wieder alt aussieht und kann jetzt
hier unten den kleber bereits an bringen
und dann das stück drum herum legen
und zum schluss muss ich jetzt noch als
lesezeichen ankleben das habe ich
bereits ausgeschnitten und geht es
direkt an die seite
jetzt ist zitate fertig und ich habe die
torten bilden und die kriegen bereits
gestern vorbereitet das hat er so etwa
15 minuten gedauert und heute habe ich
ungefähr sechs stunden dekoriert für
mich ist eigentlich eine ganz schnelle
torte denn ich habe ja nichts
vorbereiten müssen also ich hab's nicht
auf mehrere tage aufteilen müssen aber
man kann die torte natürlich auch etwas
schneller hinbekommen wenn man nicht mit
film weil es heißt ja immer ziemlich auf
morath muss noch schützen geht und so
ist es vielleicht in zwei spiel verlegt
deshalb weil man hat ja schon immer
whistler weiter zeit und man möchte auch
gut machen
ja auf jeden fall denke ich dass mein
bruder sich selbst darüber freuen mit er
weiß noch gar nichts von seinem glück
auch glück weil wir wollen ja vielleicht
bald bauen irgendwann mal dann kann er
uns die ganzen elektroinstallation meint
oder sommer hat es auf jeden fall kann
ich dir toll jetzt leider nicht
anschneiden denn mein trainer bekommt
sehr morgen geschenkt aber ja ich hoffe
ja wir lassen uns halt morgen schmecken
ja nicht schlimm wenn man auf ihrem weg
abbringen auch es geschafft hat genau
dass er in seinem leben auch es
hinbekommen hat ja man sollte meinen
bruder nadja so ist es erkennt ihn
übrigens aus meinem video aus dem video
von von dem berge hoch b genau
genau da könnten härter als schon ja der
hat halt seine ausbildung damals gemacht
und hat dann noch elektroinstallateur
gemacht elektrotechniker und keine
ahnung hatte den meister draufgemacht
finde ich echt super genau also und die
torte bekommt am morgen und ich da ich
denke erfreut sich denke ich auch glaube
ich auch
ja also dann man hat den abschluss
abschuss abschluss ok wenn er hat den
abschluss und wir machen jetzt den
abschluss auf jeden fall hoffe ich dass
ich euch ein bisschen inspirieren konnte
vielleicht packt ihr ja auch mal ein
buch nach es muss ja nicht zum abschluss
sein es gibt auch andere anlässe taufe
zum beispiel kommunionbank mir auch ganz
gerne immer mal bücher wobei das uns oft
geöffnete bücher genau genauen heute
gibt's halt bei mir eingeschlossen ist
jedenfalls viel spaß beim nachhaken und
beim dekorieren und wir sehen uns dann
beim nächsten mal bis dann
bis dann tschüss und alles noch mal dass
sein bruder in ruhe ja ali
albert der lage obwohl nicht dann das
ganze tue mache alles okay tschüss